welcome to Ordaz a lush wilderness full
of grass trees water and grass in Far
Cry primal you roamed this land
scavenging for stone raiding villages
exploring caves and heading Tigers aah
hey baby so here's a quick little
rundown on what we know from the latest
Far Cry primal demo who are you
you are taka a seasoned hunter living it
up in the recess of a now melted ice
aged glacier your ultimate goal in life
is to reconnect with your tribe and make
the now hostile world of Buddhist home
again but how in the world could you
possibly accomplish such a feat well by
liberating outposts of course you and
your animal amigo storm and take over
enemy villages scattered across the
lands charging into these villages like
animo may seem enticing at first but
there's a cool new feature up your
sleeves or on it that is pretty before
you ransack that Hut send in your trusty
owl this fully controllable and
upgradable owl allows you to scout and
spot targets upgrade the owl to do
things like I don't know dive down
talons first and rip someone's throat
out once you got free planning out of
the way it's time to seal the deal
charge the village with your trusty
animal sidekick which is the real hero
in Far Cry primal at any point can you
dismiss your pet for another animals in
the wild are obtainable by taming simply
find a furry friend and toss some meat
BAM new best friend of the different
types of animals some of which have
different secondary functions bears and
saber-tooth Tigers for instance are
rideable through upgrades and supposedly
the woolly mammoth supposedly
so after you send in one of your besties
it's your turn baby start off with the
classic bow and arrow or chuck in a
spear or maybe get up close and personal
with the hatchet or how about really
getting the party started with some good
old-fashioned beads it's up to you other
than that you'll find other things to do
in Oros stumble upon a cave like that
arrow up and start exploring you can
expect to find wildlife rare loot and
wall-painting collectibles inside these
areas or maybe you're more of a sociable
guy head into a nearby village and help
out the locals with their borer problem
who knows you might just get some
barbecue pork out of it again this demo
is just a taste of what far cry primal
has to offer so be sure to check out
GameSpot for all of your future Far Cry
needs
you